[Music]
I'm just I'm just moving my participants
over to one side of the screen here
because when you put the presentation up
all I got was the the videos of
everybody's attending and the list of
speakers disappeared so I'm just getting
that back on again me Chris you good to
go now as well on YouTube yeah I see
well okay well good morning to everybody
and good morning to those who've joined
this plants committee meeting on YouTube
I have just a couple of things to read
welcome to everybody this is a virtual
meeting of the plants committee of the
2nd of July and there's just a few basic
rules for this meeting I'll go through
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones except mine please leave
all microphones muted
unless you're asked to speak by by me to
speak there will be the normal public
participation item at the start of the
meeting rez it well the application
stage there will be residency want to
speak access exercise their right this
right they've been asked to register in
advance and we've got three speakers
I'll mention those at the appropriate
time and once the public speakers have
finished they will stay in on zoom'
obviously to hear the debate by the
committee and to to know what the result
of that debate is um and we've got three
people registered to speak today
to indicate to me that you'd like to
speak or proposed or a second emotion
please press the raised hand symbol
there's a blue raised hand there that
you should all see and in the
participants menus on your screen your
participants menu on the
Green and that that will flag up on the
screen in front of me in the order that
people want to speak and I can go
through that list in the order them I've
just said that to ensure clarity and
accuracy during the virtual meetings all
votes will be cast via a verbal recorded
vote and names will be read out in
alphabetical order please state your
vote clearly and slowly when your name
is read out a muting and muting your
microphone as necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with the direct democratic
process I've already mentioned this this
meeting is being live-streamed on the
council's YouTube channel we are in very
strange times and I ask you all to be
patient particularly with me during this
meeting and to understand that processes
and advice may take a little longer than
usual we don't want to rush anything
through and if we do have glitches in
and out there with us on that I'll now
ask each committee member to introduce
themselves and the committee clerk to
read out the names in alphabetical order
so Sandra if you do that please
yes Jerry Thank You councillor Felton we
have apologies for councillor brang yes
thank you
great Terry Sorry Sorry cancer brain
yeah person and I represent in great
Torrington Thank You Chancellor Christie
Chancellor Cragie good morning I
represent pencil who live there good
morning everybody again yes I represent
Northern Water hence no luck
good morning I represent the ward of two
rivers and three moles cancel Emma goth
so I'm not sure where the plants and the
macaque is present at the meeting he's
not no he's not a present cancel Watson
yeah Pete Watson Brodie
Chancellor Wiseman
Oh I represent the ward for shabbier and
Langtry and can't salute James who's
substituting good morning I represent
Milton and time our site which is hopes
with the roar
Thank You counselors lovely thank you
for that everybody so we'll get into the
agenda properly now in the first item on
the agenda is apologies for absence
Unruh yes chair I have one apology
canceled about two with councillor James
substituting thank you
item two on the agenda then is the
minutes of the last meeting committee
meeting held on the fourth of June and
they're on pages or I'll just go through
the page numbers at the bottom page 4
page 5 page 6 page 7a jh9
if somebody would like to propose those
minutes and setting them against the one
to a lockdown three yeah I propose we
accept the minutes thank you a lot
councillor Watson yeah I propose that we
accept the minutes you're second in them
then I am now then it's been been
proposed by counsel Locke seconded by
Councillor Watson to accept those
minutes
sounder could you read everybody open
alphabetical order to give their vote
please
yes Thank You chair pence on the brown
yes agree councillor Christie o Kansan a
craggy or don't see James okay not in
the meeting
Thank You councillor leather or can't
look
councillor Watson or and councillor
Wiseman or Thank You chair that's seven
four and one abstention
Thank You Sandra right item three on the
agenda is declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest when the
item is being considered elected members
of Devon County Council and town and
parish councils
who have considered a planning
application by virtue of their
membership of that council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not dine the members concern who
considered the application of fresh just
get rid of that frog item four on the
agenda I have my hand raised
there's no did you press the blue yeah
you know nothing's come up counselor
what's sorry council Wiseman thank you
just I just want to clarify there what
the application we're gonna hear this
morning is only a few hundred yards away
from my house and I call it in my
correcting shoo-shoo man I don't have to
declare an interest Stace a comment I
think you've declared the interest
councillor Wiseman and fight by
mentioning that and you're fine to
proceed okay thank you
right item four on the agenda is the
agreements of the agenda between parts
one and two well there isn't any part
two and so I'll move on then to item 5
argent matters and I have no urge of
masses and I don't think in a Shawn as
or anybody else items that can unlock
yeah just was just act as the offices in
the message that's coming out from the
government build build build and they're
going to be you know many of the
planning laws so we have any indication
and when that's going to happen or any
ideas of what it's going to be and I
assume that the officers come through
well with we are going to have a chat
Shawn's going to update us on that at
the end as a meeting once we've the
formal part of the major then go I'm
getting I'm getting the blue hands on
the pictures of members but I'm not
getting the blue hands on the
participants list which normally does
Joe what's happen with that so I'm not
getting the full list as I eat balls
before and I've only got 1 2 3 4 5 5
faces on the screen here
I might have to rely on Tom to tell me
if people want to speak at your
participant list I think you'll probably
be fine Matt you're you're you need to
scroll up up to the top of it and then
you'll see there'll be a few of us at
the top to our co-host including
yourself and then you'll start seeing
the hands raised if certain if one
counts like you just raise that hand for
me a second can you see counselor
Wiseman's now only on this one is a
picture of another on the participants
is a little bar on the right hand side
of the participants you're probably at
the bottom of the the list if you move
that bar to the right the participant up
you'll you'll move to the top of the
list then that's when you start being
the raised hand alright yeah yeah you've
got if you leave it like that then all
the raised hands will appear there right
I should have Saul right I should have
scrolled up to the top then got it thank
you
that's all right okay and item six on
the agenda future site visits well we
had a virtual site visit for today's
application and went very well last week
but there's nothing listed yet for the
August meeting on no doubt there will be
though item seven
public participation and I never advised
the committee that we've got three
speakers we've got a member from Patrick
Stowe parish council but I don't know if
they're with us yet don't know it is to
speak to the application as I said
earlier on when welcoming Malcolm Busby
who's to speak against the application
he'll speak secondly after the parish
council and then Stephen sherry the
agent the applicant will speak third so
they're the speakers I've got listed
this morning right we move on then to
item 8 on the agenda appears decisions
on pages 10 to 13 there's only one
listed there the one down at Appledore
so that's there for noting costs there
are no costs and any appeals item 9 item
10 is the delegated AGM amv decisions
and they are on pages 14 and that brings
us round then to item 11 planning the
applications and the information and
recommendations and advice contained in
the reports are correct at the date of
preparation which is more than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting due
to these time constraints any changes or
necessary updates to the reports will be
provided in writing or orally at the
committee meeting and we move on then
from that to our applique the only
application we've got before us this
morning which is application 1 oblique 0
2 4 6 oblique 2020 it's an outline
application on pages 15 to 20 of your
agenda and this is for an application it
land south of rectory rise better up
still and christian evilly is the
planning officer will take
through this presentation so Chris over
to you thank you thank you for the
instruction share so I need not repeat
what's on the screen but it's for free
dwellings in Patrick's though there are
a couple verbal updates firstly there's
been two objections received between the
reports and now in summary they mention
highways danger the cynical timing of
the development and people locals don't
want it and there's an objection to the
ecology banks as they made a shock
refuse and interfere with runner in
addition we've received an update from
Devon cans accounts all highways there
was a couple updates I see one
requesting a list with more information
that information was then provided and
then a subsequent update was that there
was then no objection in particular
there was concerns raised the road width
from it being four point seven meters
it's now been widened to five point five
meters with a white line down the middle
so that it's a jewel clearly separated
jewel lane piece of road in that middle
has also improved visibility splays
shown and that's all for the bird
updates moving on to the location of
development says within the rural
settlement of pet rocks though you can
see a site plan here as its described as
land suburb right through advise and
then you can see the access off right to
revise so I would find the drawing
screen but I'll just forget that and but
you all know where the access is which
is
who've got the illustrative site layout
plan bear in mind this is an outline
application with all matters except
access so this is illustrative the only
thing that cannot change is the access
so you wouldn't technically be approving
this plan this shows an area location of
the site in this context so you can see
that the size of the rural settlement
from here and by the lancets it does
slope from south being the high ground
north being lower and hopefully that'll
come across in the poses
so this is a view of the entrance living
up the field and then from in the
highway we've got a view from the
interest in Northwest and a view from
the interest looking south east then as
we go up the field I've tried to
illustrate the site plan on the right to
indicate what position I'm standing in
on the field and where the photos been
taken from as it's looking from within
the site looking south west view north
west you can see the residential
properties along rectory rise there this
is view from living beside looking back
towards the access that slopes downwards
this is looking east towards research
with dwellings and bungalows and you can
see the hedgerow screening there this is
looking south west towards the top of
the site whereas hydro-screen this is
approximately on where the site will
finish it doesn't take up the entirety
of the field so there'll be new
hedgerows separating this from the
remaining build this is a view from
within the site looking West
again it doesn't go all the way along
here so there would be a new hedgerow
it's a Google image system actually from
rectory rise it's true Jason society
looking Northwest long highway towards
site entrance this is the other side of
the entrance
looking east towards it again on rectory
rise and it's a Google view of the
settlement as you drive and enter down
looking west so move on to what plans
you would be considering suit what
location plan here
a detailed entrance plan and and some
cross-sections here which show that the
road itself would be built down rather
than built up these the material
planning considerations you see from
what officer report or considering the
proposal in light of the planning
balance and I pass back to chair to
introduce any third party speakers thank
you Chris thank you for that
presentation well our first speaker I
don't know if we've caught anybody from
the parish council this morning or not
they were listed to speak can I speak
who's that oh yeah well Malcolm you're
you're listed to speak as the second
speaker as a member of the public not as
the parish council rep you are me on
mute
Malcolm Busby at the minute Malcolm
you're down to speak as just a member of
the public not as a parish council but
uh I think there's been some you know oh
you remember as a parish council I'm the
vice chair of the parish council yes
right so do you want to speak on behalf
of the parish council yes I do yes
please
so that'll be your one time to speak and
you won't be speaking again after that
no no of course no
okay all right Malcolm you carry on then
okay thank you so you've got three
minutes okay okay how about our baton
then in light of the Torah jizz recently
adopted plan where Petrov stay has been
identified as a rural area it seems
inconceivable that planning would be
granted for this development there are
approximately a hundred and thirty
dwellings in the center of the village
going up to 200 in the wider area there
is currently approval for 20 houses in
petcocks trail 10 at sink ops five at
berry farm five at Hall would farm these
developments are close to the center
these prospective development
developments more than served the
parishes needs for the future
particularly as the village has little
infrastructure no doctor surgery no
school no shop and one ring ride bus a
week which means cars are its it are
essential I'm not sure this but none of
these developments if I'm correct
provide affordable housing the lane
through the village has no pavements
people walk their dogs frequently
children walk to catch the school bus
several residents use mobilities futures
and we have many cyclists from the
target rail the access to this proposal
site particularly difficult and the plan
of solution is to make the site more
visible by placing cobbled type rumble
strips out into the road so that the
give way line will protrude into the
existing roadway effectively having the
actual width of the lane but I think
this has been that addressed earlier
this will not improve this ability and
all of the aforementioned groups who
have to swerve into the road to avoid
these strips putting them at risk from
oncoming traffic
this traffic includes large farm
machinery from an expanding agricultural
contractors at petrol station then they
are in the process of doubling their
already considerable barn space and from
Cottle's farm also there are a lot
lorries which exit new road opposite the
access the parish council voted
unanimously to object to this proposal
and we believe that the recent local
plan should be adhered to in this
instance thank you for listening to me
Thank You counselor boss me thank you
for that and you'll be you'll be muted
again for the rest of meeting but at
least you can hear what said and the
debate when it starts and I'll go to mr.
Steven sherry who's the agent for the
applicant and Steven you've got three
minutes also to present on behalf of the
applicant
thank you sure the reality is that in
rural villages across the whole of torij
they have to share dr. schools post
offices with other villages all that
larger settlements that's just the
reality of storage there are lots of
facilities in Padstow there's the mr.
pub the laurels doing there are two
churches it's a recreational ground a
cricket club a quick player a village
hall it's self contained in many ways
and the population of metrics those
around 400 this makes it one of the
larger villages in torrid as part of the
proposal we have included a new Devon
hedge Bank around the premise of the
site and that's to provide that
ecological gain which is a policy
requirement talking about the access
most of the roadways through through the
village are less than four point eight
meters wide and as you see the amended
drawings are vendors in widened to 5.5
mm we have agreed the access
arrangements with my ways the reality is
that village speed is in the 20 to 25
mile an hour category this proposal is
only three houses the site this site was
originally allocated for those who might
remember in the old rural plan so it has
been recognized as a potential
development site many years ago in terms
of overlooking of the existing
properties as you can see we're quite a
long way above them on the slope and the
normal policy requirements is 12 21
metres separation
we've actually got 32 so we're well away
from the existing properties and we're
not going to
overlooking them there's plenty of gaps
between them we want the properties to
have views between or not looking into
their back gardens so in summary the
relatives are well sighs then each with
ample community facilities the site for
three dwellings is related to the
village it's in the middle the other
reassurance the council don't have a
five-year houses supply therefore
there's a presumption in favor of
development and three hours is in this
site are more likely to appeal to the
self building community so you'll be a
very successful site I know the officers
mate xi recommend that patients become
district complying with all of those
conditions thank you Joe
thank you mister sherry right I noticed
that councillor McGough is joined but
you've joined us the meeting started so
I don't think you're able to take part
in the meeting there because you've
missed a whole presentation etc but I'll
we've got speakers Chris did you want
I've got counsel not from the council
Chris evilly Chris you've got your hand
up did you want to comment on before I
go to council a lot yep sorry chair I
forgot to mention that my recommendation
is one of approval subjects conditions I
should have gone to the final slide and
so sorry about that
and I passed feedback sick that's a lot
I forgive you for that we've got to
cancel a lot please doesn't a
clarification if you turn to page 17
doesn't get any council highways their
very last comment says if approve the
proposal shall be subject to further
road safety audit in and deeds out and
this statement is also mentioned again
on page 22 bullet point three point
seven but is this there'll be overridden
by the latest comments might new could
all with that statement still apply
and somebody answer that either shoulder
or Chris yeah no problem and we actually
have Mike here with us so if you if you
want we can get him to come back on that
one just apply replies I'm so in my
opinion there's no need for and
additional safety or playing perspective
we could accomplish and they would then
need detailed design works later stage
in order because they're doing works to
that public highway and that would be
separate from the planning process
they'd have two gates Devon County and
because essentially they're doing works
on that land and Devon County with them
to maintain that so from a planning
perspective
I don't consider there is but from a
Democratic Council perspective if they
may want more information regarding what
works are going one site all right
councillor Wiseman no he's got his hand
up Thank You Chad I did fight called
this decision in originally on a matter
of the fact that Patrick stone what I
said had fourteen outstanding plan of
admissions it's actually 20 I wasn't
correct two of those I believe around
two of them will be for affordable
housing on a development with a larger
development village and you know we
there's an important principle just two
that I thought needed discussing here
around sustainability and the load which
the rural settlements have to carry in
regards to the five-year housing land
supply this will be twenty houses
already that's something like 15 percent
of how many dwellings are already in the
village it's quite you know it's quite
substantial for a small place but the
more I look at this the more I think the
big issue is the access road safety
access I think there are still some big
questions that haven't been
satisfactorily answered I have in front
of me
the
wrote safety audits from last year from
2019 I think it's probably the original
one that was playing last year and the
auditors were concerned that drivers may
follow the normal curb line and give way
line and drive over the granite setts as
a matter of course which will lead
vehicles at the give way to be struck by
passing vehicles their answer to this
the recommendation to this was to push
the give way line further out into the
road now the question is that they
haven't this road safety audit only
really addresses the the vision the
visual displays and so forth
it doesn't really address apart from
that statement how wrote users on the
main road would be affected and it would
be but they try to place something like
a chicane in the road and I agree with
this audit that wrote you vehicles will
travel on the on the normal natural
curve of the road they will straddle the
give way line and there will be a
conflict of vehicles there which will
end up causing accidents as as it says
in the in the road safety audit and I
can't see why pushing them pushing the
give way line out further into the road
would affect it very much because don't
forget vehicles will be travelling down
this driveway
they weren't just suddenly appear at the
give way line wonderfully what if
anybody could speak to that point
well perhaps night Mike Newcomb perhaps
I'll answer those points that you make
analyzed but of course I think I think
the safety audits on the planning portal
and probably everyone's seen that you're
quite right it was picked up by the
safety auditors I think they went on to
recommend a solution which has been
implemented by the design now that's
actually fairly unusual normally I think
only actually see it about three times
where an engineer who's conducted a
safety or it will actually put forward a
recommendation because what that does is
it negates any future of all
they could have in safety order saying
because maybe effectively became part of
the design team so they're no longer
independent I would say what they have
done has been implemented and I would
say just looking at the access itself
and and I should also point out so I
think he probably just backtracking
slightly is that the recommendation was
made by Matt Collins he can't make it
today he's also submitted the most
recent update he can't make it this
morning so I'm stepping in and just just
filling his boots but what I would say
is that the changes have been made is
that now the new the new access the
actual main road passed it if he's noted
that it is five point five meters and
according to manual for streets which is
our engineering Quran if you like you
know that actually gives us the guidance
that allows two large vehicle to larger
vehicles to pass
you're quite right it does provide new
curb lines that there is a realignment
of curb lines which will effectively
guide traffic around the corner as well
as the give way line as well as a
centerline
and the updated information that's been
provided also allows exceptional
visibility in the direction what I would
say is this I believe that this I've
spoken to both the planning officer and
to the agent and we've said that this
does because there has been an
alteration to this there does need to be
a further safety ogre and this could
this can be added as a condition okay
compared to white what counsel I
shouldn't come back on that Thank You
chair yeah so I think really mr. Newcomb
thank you for your input you've really
just highlighted the information is
already available to me yeah though I've
studied a great length and if another
safety audit has to be conducted they're
not the principal of this being a safe
exit hasn't really been proved as it the
principal is that it's not it's not
really safe but and we need another
safety audit to be able to check on that
and I don't
because the unusual nature of this
Junction and the fact that I believe
it's not safe in the way it's
constructed at the moment but the speed
of 20 to 25 miles an hour's mentioned
well I I travel this road a great deal
and that somewhat surprises me to be
honest I can't ever remember anybody
noticing anyone do 20 miles an hour let
alone or even 2530 is much much more
common I don't think I can support this
at the moment just on safety grounds of
that Junction and I think the safety
road safety audit tells us as much there
I saw I won't be supporting this
application on those grounds mr. Newcomb
you want to come back yeah sure so just
to clarify two things no I agree does
absolutely need to be safety orders
again and that can be added as a
condition with regards to the speeds
you're right I think speeds
I think Matt Matthew did mention 20 to
25 in his comments I think that was
mentioned in the safety audit but the
further information that's provided
there's cater for speeds of 30 miles an
hour and that's why the the agent
revised the visibility space okay Chris
you want to come back and then I'll
bring counsel magoffin Thank You Chad so
me Mike did have a telephone
conversation regarding this as indicated
I wasn't aware that it was completely
necessary but it does sound like if you
are approving this then from what mr.
Newcomb and also canceled Wiseman have
indicated that noose if told it would be
necessary this wouldn't mean that
highways objecting and indeed they are
raising the objection we could we could
put a pre commencement condition on this
application it wouldn't need any
agreement was the applicant application
and that would allow for additional
scheme of road safety auditing prior to
any current taking place and if any
these has come up at that point which
they kind
become then of course the application
can't be implemented
equally if the rotate tilt is fine when
they could take me go ahead Chris before
I bring council locking again councillor
McGough yeah thinking about fishermen
and I've been every chore axes my wife I
I'm currently sat on bit of my cars you
probably see just clarification assist
at least I've obviously I'm about a site
visit personally on this site and I'm in
receipt of the agenda that's been sent
out and yet I can't vote on what were
just I said no because I've missed a
presentation but the information I need
is in black and white in front of me
today to make a decision can I have some
clarity of Mississippi's and obviously I
apologize not been able access Wi-Fi but
thank you Stacy if you just like that as
I understand it if a good counsel is not
present at the start of a meeting you
can't come in and join it partway
through but Stacy would you just like to
clarify that position please
Thank You counsel ever I think the other
difficulty counselor McGough is that
there are two public speakers so I think
you came in after they had both spoken
so we added Malcolm Busby who was
against the application and Steve and
sherry who was for the application and
you haven't had the benefit of listening
to their representations in respect of
the matter and as I think it does
patient a difficult position in respect
of not being able to consider all the
available evidence and representations
that have been in front of the plants
committee this morning thank you for
that
I'm sorry councilman Gossett that's the
position but that that is what the
position is so when counsel a lot now
you've got your hand up to speak yeah it
seems the whole application seems
absolutely hinge on the safety aspect
now I can't see the point person I
cannot see the point if this application
is approved today put it on an extra
condition
for an extra safety oh yeah and then
when the exercise dude it comes back and
it may be not possible you know then the
application has been approved already
sup that condition can we not defer this
and ours and give to the applicants time
to carry out this extra safety order and
then we've know exactly where we stood
yeah councillor McGough do you want to
come I'll go back to Christian it can
look off yeah famous seven table see I
can't take place in this discussion now
Dan but taught me savor the rest of them
remain in the meeting or so I just leave
well you can remain in the meeting now
if you like or leave it it's entirely up
to you council McGough Chris I'll go
back to you now I'm so it wouldn't it
wouldn't necessarily be completely
unreasonable it's just the further
meeting too secretive a very safety
audit that would be a decision for the
members I do think we can condition it
and if you would be more comfortable
with an additional safety audit and
that's something that we can certainly
defer for there would be a very minor
risk that the applicant could simply
appeal our decision not to make it all
to defer a decision because it would
then be comfortably the word but we
wouldn't have made a decision so they
could appear essentially for knowledge
generation that's the one find key him
but I think that's that's it really it
will be a decision for us and there's no
councillor Brown wants to speak kind of
bring Shawn Harrington in first and then
we'll go to councillor Brown thank you
Thank You councillor lever full of
benefit over public viewing the sheep
feed my name's from height a moment
111 manager at Asura council yeah just
to clarify where we are with this from
the highway issues we have had the
updated response from the highway
authority who have no objection as we've
heard from mr. Newcomb today no it's
possibly some concern about a further
audit that is required however there is
comfort that in the admission that we've
got such an audit is likely to be
positive and therefore we as officers
feel it is appropriate to place a pre
commencement condition on this however
if members are minded to defer the
application I would suggest the phone
application for two cycles given the
implications of the corona virus
pandemic and actually for the agent to
get a harry's officer out decide to do
the safety audit it may be unreasonable
to do that within a few weeks which
would be required from one cycle plans
committee thanks Thank You councillor
Brown okay yeah I'm quite concerned
about the access it's very seat to get
into isn't it and I wondered if any
considers consideration has been made to
people who may want to walk in and out
with that some people do walk not
everybody has a car and I wonder how
disabled people would be able opes
safely and has that been being
considered thank you it might preclude
anybody with a disability from dying I
know it's only three houses but there
are three houses Chris you come back on
that and then night Newcomb thank you
sure yes so we have considered the
steepness of the ground
it wouldn't be some English necessary
concerns since me is my office so there
are many sites which are on Steve ground
and the gradient doesn't seem as max
gradient of 7% which isn't particularly
steep and it wouldn't in my opinion
result in any significant danger and
preclude anyone from walking up and down
it
Thank You Ike Newcomb
yeah sorry just to press the hand button
I should wait for Chris's fee because I
agree with everything he's just said but
also there is a suitable footpath that
leads into the site as well so
pedestrians will be segregated from
traffic that was the only point in
hadrat thank you
I always like to hear the views of those
who want to speak
I always think chairman should conduct
the meeting and then their views should
come perhaps last or towards the end so
I'll just read out what I've written and
I've looked at this application very
carefully and I noticed from Chris's
report the balance it's a very finely
balanced application this but I do look
him back notice they're only 12 months
ago just over in April last year this
more or less identical application was
excuse me
I had my under yeah I see hands just
cannot cancel Watson all right
don't mind I see yeah and just in April
last year this was recommended by the
planning officer refusal it was against
policies now I'll read out what I
printed out yesterday as my view
achieving sustainable development means
that the planning system is three
overarching objectives did indeed Chris
mentions these in his report one is an
economic objective second is a social
objective and thirdly is an
environmental objective and the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development and people keep talking
about the presumption in favor of
development but they miss out the word
sustainable does not change the
statutory status of the development plan
as the starting point for decision
making and I think more or less that's
what Chris has put in his report Petric
Stowe is a rural settlement in our local
plan
it's classed as a rural settlement and
hear what mr. sherry says it is a large
rural settlement in no case no case for
local occupancy dwellings has been
provided but with the application so
these are just gonna open market
dwellings planning approvals in the area
because there's been mention of thing
already account for ten houses and
eleven barn conversions which one would
imagine and provide sufficient future
housing for the route this rural
location in rural settlements which
contain at least one prescribed service
or community facility appropriately
located development of a moderate scale
will be enabled to meet locally
generated needs and that for me is a key
bit locally generated needs i hear what
mr. sherry said also that villages and
rural settlements do share in the wider
area with facilities and that petra
style does have some in an attempt to
make the access safe and suitable for
all users which includes what we've
heard plenty pedestrians and people on
horses going by on that road this hybrid
scheme for me is proposed to take
account of the fact that the access is
on the inside of the bend the rumble
strips proposed could still propel heavy
vehicles into the path of vehicles and
pedestrians exiting the site so for me
there is a safety serious safety aspect
here with us there is a presumption in
favor of sustainable development where
we cannot demonstrate a five year supply
of deliverable housing sites will accept
them but the key word here is
sustainable and in my view this is a
nonstic unsustainable location along
with the safety aspects three open
market dwellings in this location would
have a negligible impact on the housing
requirements of torij and I did I've got
a proposal here but I see counselor
Watson wants to speak so I'll go to
councillor Watson and show must come in
councillor Watson first and then Sean
okay thanks Thank You Jay sorry to
interrupt you that didn't mean it I
thought she bites me um yeah I'm looking
to retool now and
okay you talk about sustainability but I
always come back with this with this new
new thing and there's no objection
anymore to wit to it I know we they're
looking at doing another thing but
there's no objection landscaping I think
there's gonna be no impact on residents
no overlooking and it's good that we put
a shorter time condition on it to two
years but for me there's also some
material considerations to take into
into consideration which is the bare
wood appeal for a start in Torrington
you know we may not like it but this did
happen and we all read what what the
inspector had put and as I said before I
wake highways of no objection we've got
no five-year land supply and I feel that
if this went to an inspector our
planning department would not be able to
have a robust defense against this
decision pavements most villages ain't
got no pavement anyway and if I know I
know mr. book mr. Bush misspoke well but
if if he if this went to an appeal
mr. Busby's evidence wouldn't be
wouldn't be let be there because we have
got a way saying that it's safe now I
didn't realize that there was pubs
public cetera in in pet rocks though
because I don't think I've ever been
through pet rocks though and the
applications that are already there
they're not forced to come to fruition
so for me I've been looked at all this I
would propose that we that we grant it
and and if anybody wants to do second it
that's fine okay that's all on each leg
Thank You chair and you can so what's
Sean Harrington there Thank You council
ever there's a few things to pick out
there I think
which may need some clarification
certainly in relation to the five-year
housing that supply as councillor watson
stated the recent appeal at Byrd in
Torrington inspector in headed towards
gesture council can no longer
demonstrate a five-year housing that
supply the impact of that is that and
paragraph eleven day of the NBP F we
need to consider planning closes in
light of the Tilted balance and to do so
we need to weigh the harms and the
benefits in the balance of each
application as it comes before us we can
still take into account leader element
plan and the policies within that and
it's for committee members to serve as
decision-makers to give your weight to
those policies in this balance you'll
notice from the officers committee
report that we stated less in terms of
the balance is finally balanced and the
officer has stated ly weight to each
element within the committee report
I allowed moderate weights to the
provision of three new dwellings in the
area in relation to the settlement
classification I think it's probably
quite important with regard to pet rocks
though and its its classification as a
rural settlement in our settlement
hierarchy a settlement hierarchy study
was conducted as part of the local plan
the drafting of our adopted local plan
which was accepted by the clan inspector
we forgot to pet rocks toe the reason
that why wasn't classed as a village was
it failed on two points the first one
was that there was no convenient shop or
school in the in the settlement and the
second one was due to limited access to
public transport while so is a bus stop
there I believe that the regularity of
the bus is fairly poor in petwalk stone
so that was the reason why it's classed
as a real settlement as opposed to
village
despite its physical size and the other
cities that reduce
a hedgehog Stern I think that's probably
quite important members may also wish to
consider the proximity to surrounding
settlements now in the Tilted balance
and how sustainable this would be regard
to supporting schools I was where
merchants fairly close I believe that's
where the primary school is a medical
center in Black Point and also
reasonably close which could all be
added to the discussion and the planning
balance in terms of the highway impact
again that would be partly plan balance
and it could be considered that there's
negative all there's negative weight
let's harm got to the safety due to the
the highways solution although we have
heard from Denton County Council as a
highway authority that there is no
objections and there could be fair
solutions with regard to a audit study
on that access if members were minded to
refuse refuse or the application they'd
have to be carefully worded regarding
that reason for fusable in light of the
tilt balance and the negative impacts in
negative impacts
Demond stably outweigh the benefits of
the scheme happy to take any questions
on this because it is quite a complex
subject from any other members of
committee thanks I've got my new come to
speak and then councillor James I'm
sorry castle Locke and councillor James
thank you I just wanted to clarify one
thing and that was I didn't want to put
anyone a gum tree about the safety
always I would say that it is an ongoing
process
so even when sits built the safety audit
process goes on we have a stage three
order and we also have a post opening
monitoring which is stage 4 order as
well so I just wanted to explain like I
said that is an ongoing situation is a
fluid situation and come people pointed
out like highways haven't raised
objections against the against the
application counselor lock yeah I mean
someone mentioned just now the public
speaker mentioned about how many
proposed houses they're already in none
of which has yet been built out and we
were always told in our training just to
consider the application in front of you
so you can't think well you know they
might be built on they might not be
built all these other houses the
important perhaps is yes as counts of
Watts allude you'd say we have not got
five year plans of long and I was
pleased to read in the report that we if
it is a proven to be on condition that
work should start in two years rather
than we already bought three years
highways have got no objections and I
assume if it is approved we will put in
an extra condition about the safety
audit report so on balance and it is a
very balanced decision I don't think
that the negatives outweigh the
positives so I would second counselor
Watson's recommended approval Thank You
counsel a lot councillor James Thank You
chair slight reservations about the
entrance to the site because they are is
on an inside been that is being dealt
with thoroughly by the highways
regard to the sustainably the
sustainability of the community there
are there are very few finished shops in
any villages these days this is just a
change of shop in practice and it's a
fair sized village there are schools in
the area very close by and there
obviously needs to be those schools
sustained because I've seen it in my
rural area where we have villages no
that are included in development plan
for the shots of closed and the schools
have closed because those plans have not
come to fruition I I would support it
because I feel that it is a sustainable
community it has a church
it has a poem as a whole cricket ground
and everything how much more do you want
because you won't get shots in villages
these days just dunk you're not getting
shots in the high street this is a
changing style of life and I feel that
the problem with this one a little bit
is that the classification of the
village it's been a rural settlement
rather than the fact it is a thriving
village just missing some of the things
that are not in any villages these days
and you're in danger if you're going to
say you have if it hasn't got a shot
Transport has also got quite remote in
rural areas and I declare there that I'm
a director of the doing of my service
that does service this area so I feel
that on the balance and it is a balance
that I would be in favor of the
development thank you Joe
thanks counselor James councillor
Wiseman yeah Thank You chair I'm just
you know coming back to the safety audit
really it's what at what point is
stopping us safety audit because the
author made a recommendation who audited
his recommendations he's a designer now
isn't he not the auditor I don't think
that's that's not secure that's not
right way of carrying on I don't think
we have to have it either all of it or
reject it this the design he proposed
Chris come back on that thank you so
yeah as how is it pointed out it is an
unusual scenario going forward in Ferber
auditors what would have happened now is
the person that Stephen sherry has used
or the applicant or agent has used to
audit that would essentially have to
step back there'd have to get a new
auditor in but I wouldn't preclude the
application necessarily being
unacceptable which is just an unusual
circumstance and I'm sure might be able
to
right well if nobody else wants to speak
on this now
the issue the main issue does seem to be
the actual and really that's all that's
down to for consideration in this
outline application is the access at the
end of the day but there are issues over
that but if it is proposed councillor
Watson's proposed that this is granted
and councillor Locke seconded it but
with the condition added of an another
safety or a new safety audit done is
that correct
is that what counsel Watson and come
Sherlock that's fine that's fine by me
chair yeah I'm sure that that given that
if it is approved it will get done
can I go stand up perhaps the officer
can read out what word in this show
knowing too much to come in there yeah
yeah it's good to clarify if that's is
the recommendation can we defer the
wording of the condition two officers in
conjunction with the chair by share
plans committee yeah if that's
acceptable to councillor Watson accounts
a lot yeah that's fine okay yeah well
it's been proposed and seconded nobody
else wants to speak to grant this
application can either send us to take
the vote in alphabetical order please
Thank You chair penciler Brown Gore
cancer Christie Oh
councillor Cragie against Kent so James
or councillor leather for cancer lock or
cancel Watson or and councillor Wiseman
gangs Thank You chair that's six four
and two against okay thank you for that
saundra
thank you everybody will now move on the
next item on the agenda
but I can find me agenda here planning
decisions on pages 32 37 I'll just go
through the pages of one by one so you
go page 30 31
these are delegated decisions 32 in the
main now 33 page 33
page 34 page 35 cancel the lock I'm
getting ready for page 36
you've been preemptive strike oh yeah
yeah page 36 then cancel a lot
non-determined dean permissions that
raise my eyebrow Clary Vice all eight
that means yeah of course it looks like
a new one that one doesn't it what that
was in relation to was a cultural prior
approval application and K so now it
says that we can't actually make a
formal decision about whether stomachs
committed development or not as a prior
approval it would have to be for a
certificate low for this application and
as such we can't make it a formal
decision hence not determined deem
permission they fly explains all right
so where are they with that particular
application then so yeah and it's a
difficult one to explain and out
cultural permitted development they have
to fulfill a few caveats it has to be
within certain criteria it could be our
informal view as it was in this case and
that it didn't meet that criteria but
what we can't do is formally issue a
decision saying it's not permitted
development we don't have the right
under prior rule to do that
so what we
saying there is it's not a formal
decision but it doesn't meet the
criteria of committed development okay
so they can leave the building up and
carry on then they don't have to submit
no what it means is if they could be
building up it has under care its
enforcement action right okay thanks for
that thanks for bringing that up Council
no I did I did wonder about that one and
page 37 is the last page and that
completes the planning plans committee
meeting for the 2nd of July so thank you
to everybody who's taking part thank you
for anybody's watched on YouTube I hope
you found it interesting because it was
quite a lot to discuss on that
application will now leave YouTube
Thanks